it makes up 60 of the human body and
seventy percent of the earth's surface
is covered with it scientists have found
evidence for it on the Moon in space and
even on Mars
it's one of the most abundant compounds
in the known universe I can never leave
a Starbucks without spending at least a
sawbuck a venti a 20 but there's one
thing that's always free if you ask
nicely
and that's a venti cup of water a
ventiagua
and it tastes pretty good
as I will now demonstrate
[Music]
there's actually official water tasters
that make their living from reviewing
different types of water but I bet none
of them have ever analyzed one of the
samples that I'm going to be taste
testing today Martin I heard about you
and I was fascinated you are a water
sommelier correct and you believe that
there are many types of water and
flavors of water and then it's important
to know the distinction I'm not even
believing in that I think there is
actually it's a it's a fact
ordinary H2O take two hydrogen atoms
atomic number one
on the periodic table with one proton in
the nucleus
hydrogen is the most abundant element in
the universe
and all you need to do to make your
recipe is combine it with element number
eight oxygen forming a close covalent
bond that can be very hard to break
water is very stable and all Life as we
know it requires water for its existence
life began on Earth in water
probably about three and a half to four
billion years ago soon after the Earth
formed
the total amount of water on Earth has
not really changed much since although
the form at which the water has taken
whether it's solid or liquid or vapor
has changed dramatically over the past
billions of years so where did water on
Earth come from how was it formed in the
first place in the universe and why is
there so much of it in the cosmos it's
actually far from rare it's one of the
most common compounds in the entire
universe
now Earth is the only known planet with
liquid surface water located as it is in
the so-called habitable zone surrounding
its host star our sun
some exoplanets could have a trickle or
two on Earth 97 of our water is in the
ocean
of the remaining three percent most of
that is locked up in ice at the polar
caps in the North and South
over a third of what's left is
underground
that leaves just over about one percent
of all water on Earth actually usable by
humans and other living life forms water
is pretty unique
it expands when frozen becoming less
dense as it solidifies rather than more
dense like other liquids do when they
freeze
thanks to that ice that forms in bodies
of water floats up to the surface
leaving liquid water underneath and
allows us to ice skate on top do some
ice Road Trucking and maybe do a little
bit of ice fishing for those denizens of
the deep
so water floats when solidified it
becomes less dense on top of ordinary
water as this experiment demonstrates
now that's because of the unique
polarity of water molecules
an electronegative ion and
electropositive ion come together
forming an ionic bond between them
this actually forms the wetness
properties of water which also can
create surface tension that allows some
animals or maybe even Jesus to Walk On
Water it enables the capillary action
that allows water to flow up through the
xylem and phloem if I remember from high
school biology properly inside of trees
it also causes the hexagonal structure
of snowflakes and ice crystals
the orderly crystal structure is
attributable to the almost 120 degree
Bond angle between the two hydrogens and
the oxygen put six of them together and
you get a hexagon but it's not exactly
120 degrees that's why every snowflake
will be randomly different and no two
are alike
the crystal structure also pushes the
ice molecules apart which is why water's
density decreases as it freezes shown
here
it's time to resume our tasting flight
next on the level of expensiveness is
Fiji Water
Fiji Water is about four bucks a liter
but it's still a relative bargain even
though it's infinitely more expensive
than this free Starbucks water it
allegedly comes from volcanic cisterns
on the island of Fiji
ah I can taste those volcanic minerals
the unique structure gives it natural
electrolytes and its signature soft
smooth taste it's not just water it's
Fiji Water this rain has made the same
and extraordinary Journey from the
clouds above Fiji to a sustainable
Artesian aquifer deep within the Earth
it's not just Wanda
sweet tea water next we come to the
priciest easily commercially available
water on our tasting flight Burg water
this water was allegedly trapped in an
iceberg for fifteen thousand years some
of the iceberg's ice could be as old as
a million years
these icebergs calve they break apart
and are captured and harvested at Great
risk and great cost to the ice Hunters
of the great white North
at the very top of the world a hot new
business is booming in the freezing
Waters of Newfoundland I say new but
really it's been 10 000 years in the
making the business is Iceberg
harvesting and the cold rushes on
okay
uh hmm
it's good but I miss those minerals in
fact this has almost no minerals
according to the bottle this water's
Journey started over 15 000 years ago
and the glaciers of Western Greenland
and has been safely stored in the ice
cap protected
by the ocean and the Hazardous
conditions of the Arctic weather
isolation has made its source totally
inaccessible to man
it is not until massive pieces of ice
break off into the ocean in the form of
Iceberg so they can be harvested melted
and bottled under strict quality
conditions in order to preserve the
water's natural qualities you might
think that's expensive but this fossil
ancient water is a bargain compared to
our next taste test contestant on our
flight deuterium oxide heavy water what
is heavy water
again let's go back to water at all why
is there water here on Earth where does
it all come from
to understand that we need to understand
the whole story of hydrogen Numero Uno
on the periodic table one proton and one
electron the simplest of all atoms
but it comes in many different flavors
and although ordinary hydrogen that
we're familiar with makes up over 75
percent of the baryonic matter or
ordinary matter matter such as R
composition
it's the very essence of what the
universe is made of in Terms of ordinary
matter
pales in comparison to the amount of
dark matter and we'll come to that later
it came into existence soon after the
birth of our universe itself now two
hydrogen atoms coming together and with
an oxygen make up water that we've been
discussing but there's more than one
form of hydrogen and there's more than
one form of oxygen it turns out to get
isotopic variations the number of
neutrons changes in the atom and we've
discussed that in previous videos
deuterium is the heavy older brother if
you will of hydrogen it has a proton but
it also has a proton bound to a neutron
that proton bound to a neutron makes the
molecule heavier now it doesn't double
the mass of it even though the neutron
the proton are almost the same mass
because the oxygen atom is so much more
heavy than either a deuteron which is
what we call a nucleus of deuterium or a
proton which is called the ordinary
nucleus of a hydrogen atom so the oxygen
dominates so actually heavy water is
only heavier by about 10 to 12 percent
over ordinary water at room temperature
and pressure the name hydrogen itself
means water forming and that's what
happens when the very volatile hydrogen
is ignited or combined in an oxygen-rich
environment that's what happened
unfortunately to the Hindenburg not the
Hindenburg but the Hindenburg disaster
100 years ago back then hydrogen was the
miracle molecule everybody thought what
is useful for lighter than air vehicles
and after that ill-fated inflation
balloon event we no longer use it for
that purpose
now most of the water on Earth is in the
form of ordinary hydrogen single proton
and no neutrons so most of this water on
this table has a preponderance many many
times more ordinary hydrogen than
deuterium but if you can isolate the
deuterium you can actually get a form of
water here that's 99.8 percent deuterium
in the nucleus not ordinary hydrogen in
other words this has an extra Neutron
for 998 of every 1 000 water molecules
in this bottle water this heavy water is
actually lighter even than the heaviest
form of water which is composed of
tritium nuclei tritium has three
nucleons in its nucleus it has a proton
and has two neutrons so that's three
atomic number units in each nucleus
that's why it's called tritium
deuterium is lighter and actually
deuterium the element was discovered by
the namesake of the UCSD chemistry
Department Harold Yuri who won a Nobel
Prize and actually worked on simulating
the conditions of the early Earth in an
attempt to understand the origin of life
so there's an intimate connection
between where we are right now the
chemistry department at UC San Diego and
the search for life in the universe and
how it actually came to form and perhaps
the key could involve some of the
processes that made this water but in
addition to being useful to form life it
can also slake my thirst here on a hot
San Diego morning let's try it
even more expensive than Iceberg water
this is about two hundred dollars worth
of water so I really shouldn't be
dropping it deuterium oxide what they
use it for printed on the sign
now getting tritiated water or tritium
water would be a much much more
challenging and dangerous occupation
tritium is radioactive it gives off high
energy radiation which can damage the
human body so it's a controlled
substance which can be obtained at Great
cost and risk if you have the proper
credentials which I do not
so let's do a taste test Down the Hatch
deuterium water
taste those neutrons
cost about a dollar per milliliter
making this single Ice Cube cost over 25
now we're gonna see if it'll float and
cool off a drink just as well as an
ordinary liquid H2O Ice Cube does let's
put it in this petri dish filled with
ordinary deionized water
nope this sinks basically right to the
bottom here's ordinary water with an
ordinary Ice Cube over here
made for less than one penny
that floats very nicely this one is
stuck to the bottom of the tray so d2o
or heavy water when it's frozen is more
dense than ordinary H2O meaning that it
would sink to the bottom of a pond or
body of water whereas ordinary H2O
floats on top which is why you can ice
skate on top of a frozen water ordinary
water H2O Lake in the winter time but
you couldn't do that on a planet that
only had deuterium oxide or heavy water
it's rare expensive and extremely useful
besides its weight heavy water is less
active than regular water meaning it's
harder to melt or to boil plus it
doesn't have any strong spectral
signature so it's often used for doing
nuclear magnetic resonance or nmri
experiments and for Diagnostic purposes
for human beings and other living
creatures
you could actually see the presence of
deuterium in space and it was measured
decades ago and found later to have
agreement with the cosmic microwave
background radiation that I study so
where does all the water come from well
astronomers think that water is formed
in nebulae we can actually see the
presence of water in space
in areas of other molecules hydrogen can
cool off after the cosmic Dark Ages
ended and eventually oxygen from the
formation of the very first star
so-called population three those stars
that blew up eventually will come
together and become bonded in water
molecules in space but space is very
cold so all that regular water is in the
form of ice crystals even Saturn's rings
are primarily composed of of ice cubes
not of liquid water certainly
hydrogen is the fuel of stars
through a process called the pp or
proton proton chain hydrogen Fusion
takes place and helium is created
releasing prodigious amounts of energy
helium named after the Greek god of the
sun Helios was discovered not on Earth
but on the sun and how did astronomers
discover this element crucial to the
universe's structure well they went at
night
helium number two on the periodic table
takes over and then it fuses itself in
helium and makes heavier and heavier
elements
through a process that was first
detailed by my late great colleagues
here at UC San Diego Margaret and Jeff
Burbage along with her colleagues Willie
Fowler and Sir Fred Hoyle
so helium through the process they help
to reveal along with other scientists
forms oxygen which combines with the
hydrogen to form water
Stars age they eventually run out of
that hydrogen fuel but don't worry the
sun even at the rate of burning 600
million tons a second the sun has about
4 billion good years left in it
eventually the rate of fusion in the
Stars overcome by gravity and the star
collapses forming a supernova we've
talked about that in previous videos the
oxygen produced during the explosion
that results from a type 2 Supernova
then eventually combines with hydrogen
forming water molecules again in space
the biggest clusters of interactions
happen when a lot of tiny molecules are
bunched together and they form what are
called nebulae which is Latin for clout
the stain nebulae that birth Stars also
have water molecules in them and they
also have heavier elements like Silicon
and carbon that the Earth's crust and
core and iron Etc are made up of and
eventually planets can form but there is
a lot of leftover material some cosmic
space Schmutz is not formed into planets
and is left over and if it's in the form
of water it's frozen water it becomes
what's known as a comet
comets have tremendous amounts of liquid
water that has been frozen in the fast
cool expanse of space and that means
that there's a tremendous amount of
Frozen water and an early planetary
system so water eventually got to earth
scientists believe through the
bombardment of comets hitting the early
Earth
and those initial processes were quite
violent and the water in the cometary
ice would melt on the surface of the
Earth but then later Earth froze over
and at different stages in Earth's
history it was a Frozen snowball but
later on the earth did warm up through a
variety of processes including solar
activity and radioactivity in the
Earth's crust eventually being warm
enough
to sustain liquid water on its surface
some of that frozen ice has been trapped
at the poles
and one of the places that you can
access permanently is at the South Pole
if you have special permission the South
Pole differs from the North Pole in that
if you drill down through the ice caps
at the North Pole you'll hit the Arctic
Ocean there's no continent underneath it
but in Antarctica
where I've been twice up for several
weeks at a time is underneath the ice
cap 10 000 foot thick cap of ice at the
South Pole nearly if you drill down
through that 10 000 foot very flat very
appropriate for cross-country skiing
snow base you get rock you get
Continental rocks in fact there are
volcanoes and all sorts of geological
formations that are associated with the
continent of Antarctica
and that brings us to our most expensive
Contender on the tasting flight this is
water from Antarctica from ancient ice
it's hard to calculate how much this
water cost I collected it at the South
Pole in one of my visits and stored it
in a proper scientific container I
haven't opened it since
it's over 12 years old plus about a
million years sitting on the icy frozen
continent
to get to the South Pole requires a ride
on a government transport plane
it's reserved by the National Science
Foundation for scientists in the United
States for scientists engineers And
Trades people
let's try this
million year old sip of water
ah
not too bad even if it did cost fifty
thousand dollars water is essential to
All Life as we know it but as important
as water is to life on Earth we wouldn't
even have water if there wasn't another
form of matter even more essential than
water
type of matter that holds the whole
universe together dark matter
dark matter is even more rare and
difficult to obtain than Antarctic ice
water and if you'd like to learn more
about it click on this video here
now
[Music]